my name is Karthik I will be talking
about Tudor heaven and this is kind of a
I'm trying to blend some kind of a data
engineering and some kind of a satire
science kind of problem that comes out
of running heron in operation so I'll
kind of spell out the problem and
details see whether you guys can come up
with some good solutions then you can
see whether you can contribute or not so
then actually so it's a last talk and
probably everybody will be tired so I'll
try to keep it a little bit live I'll
try to keep it live little bit but if
you guys have any questions and just
bring me at least so that we could keep
it a little bit more conversational
rather than I'm on logging all the time
okay okay so the talk outline is going
to be like first I will give a short
introduction into what Heron is and the
introduce the concept of what they call
is a micro steam engine and how we deal
with heaven when it's running at a large
scale within today and I'll zoom in on
one problem called stragglers I mean
probably everybody has heard the term
stragglers in the Hadoop world but it's
not new in the big date of context but
tights also occurs in the streaming as
well world as well then I will also have
some numbers on how the resource usage I
mean where the time really goes actually
when you run a streaming topology at a
large scale so I have a detail breakdown
into where the time actually is goes
then finally I will do a some kind of
conclusion about some of the problems
that you face so as we all know like
twitter is about real-time and there are
several aspects of real-time inventory
and some of them include real time
clients where we can continuously
compute the trending hashtags and bubble
them up so that people can consume this
information then we also have real-time
conversations where there are doing
sports and everything's a lot of
conversations are flowing in real-time
and we wanted to bubble up those popular
conversation as well and of course our
monitor is based on our injection and so
if a real-time conversation is flowing
we wanted to identify what is the
content of those real-time conversation
and accordingly inject those ads in real
time because as people are swiping
through the Twitter's timelines you
might want to make sure that you inject
the right tire that gets the attention
because ultimately and at the end of the
day when you click only we do translate
that into revenue for us so the finally
we have real-time search where the
incoming tweets are indexed as quickly
as possible so that when you go to
search at twitter.com you can search for
those tweets right away so these are the
various aspects of real time in Twitter
but all these trend to be accounted for
billions and billions of events and that
occurs in every minute to reoffer so we
need to handle all of them in real time
so that is a big challenge for us so in
order to handle all these analytics so
we have a infrastructure called hair and
which has been in production for the
last two years and I just give us some
kind of terminologies since some of you
must have heard about storm so it
essentially borrows from all the
terminologies from storm because it's
completely backward compatible because
Twitter has invested so much on storm
and all its API that we need to carry
the entire missionary without the
programmers having to change anything so
so a streaming job is called a topology
and it's nothing but a dag and all the
vertices in a dag represent the
computation and they just represent the
stream of tapas flowing through those
through those vertices and there are two
type of vertices one is called spouts
and they are the sources of data and the
sources could be anything like it could
be as a Kafka or a Kestrel my sequel or
Postgres and internally within Twitter
we are in the process of replacing Kafka
and Kestrel into something called the
even bus which is based on distributed
log and that is more than sixty percent
in production right now so then we also
have the second type of vertices called
bowls where the actual processing is
happening so in the case of machine
learning or data science problem most of
the computations will happen in those
bowls and it what it does is takes the
incoming tuples and munch them and emit
outgoing data and some of the examples
if we include from examples include the
real-time ba versus machine learning
where you have the filtering and
aggregation which is a very common
operation
so does join as well
and also some kind of an oddity function
like a clustering function or a
classification function if you want to
write based on what was a job that you
have you might be able to bolt that
coding and into a boat so I hadn't
topology looks like this so if you have
a couple of spouts which is in the first
stage which are tapping into multiple
data streams then you have the second
stage bowls which are fed from the
spouts then you have a third state bolt
which is feeding from the second state
bolts and one of the advantages of
Harran is like you can do as many stages
as you like to like we have seen jobs
ranging from ten stages to fifteen
stages so that can keep on going and so
the next difference is like here the
data is streaming there is no notion of
what he called the data is put down into
a persistent storage like a their SST or
a disk at every stage instead the data
is continuously streaming even if there
is a process failure the process gets
restarted and data streams through again
and if the mission gets fail
the job is relocated to a different node
and it continues to keep going so to
give a concrete example in the
traditional streaming world you have
this notion of a word count apology so
essentially if you want to have a
lifetime of sleep and do you wanted to
count the number of words on that live
stream of tweets the others try to treat
spout that taps into a Twitter firehose
and then what you do is like you take
the tweet and you wanted to parse the
tweet and break into words so then once
you broke the street into words then you
wanted to send it to a word count Bowl
that actually counts the words itself so
under the word count ball will spit out
how many words are occurring every
second or every few seconds depending
upon how you are configured so this in
database parlance what we used to call
is logical plan yes yeah okay okay so
it's a it's called a logical plan if
you'd know about database systems where
if you'll give an SQL query the query
gets converted into some kind of an
abstract query tree and from that query
tree and then you go and BLS a physical
plan how it's actually executed so that
query tree is essentially nothing but a
logical plan and that is efficiently
water top
is actually now in physical realization
there are a lot of issues that will
happen one is the sheer amount of data
that you might have the process is not
possible within the realm of a single
process are within the realm of a single
mission itself so in order to kind of
sustain the data rate that you might be
getting so you need to allow multiple
tweet spouts past so in other words what
we call as a parallelism so for each of
those logical plan nodes you specify how
many instances of those things have to
be running at at any given time and
these instances are distributed across
several nodes in a big cluster so so
that is what the physical realization of
a large actually logical topology looks
like so here in this case the tweet
spouts might have a like a few hundred
tasks similarly a part streetball point
however like tens of tasks and similarly
even word count bolt might be having
another hundreds of tasks so one of the
question is when a part speed bolt emits
that data where the data has to end up
in the next stage or the subsequent
stages so that is where we have this
notion of stream groupings and some of
the groupings include something called
shuffle grouping this is a random
distribution of tuples then which means
it can go to any random downstream bowls
similarly you have something called
fields grouping which goes to a bolt
based on the hash values of a fewer
attributes in the Java object or the
tupple then this is an all grouping
where you replicate to all downstream
balls and similarly you have a global
grouping where you send the entire data
to one task so with this introduction
and coming back to the word count
topology how do you annotate the
groupings so between Tower tweet spout
and parse we'd you just need a shuffle
grouping because you the tweet can land
up at any parts tweet because it's
getting just parsed whereas when you go
from parse tree to word count
you need a fields grouping because you
want the same word to end up in the same
Bowl so that the counter is accurate so
with this short introduction what did we
did Heron when we got some streaming
engines because remember Heron has been
running in production close to two years
off
development and so at the time like we
had a lot of issues with storm and one
of the major issues was to performance
predictability so we want to have
predictable performance every time when
you launch a job and so that it is going
at a predictable throughput predictable
latency and everything so then increase
the developer productivity because often
one of the major complaints that we get
was hey I'm not able to find the issue
in my job so what do I do you know so at
any given point of the day we are a
small team and we are support supporting
the entire massive today so which means
like but because of the ratio of the
number of jobs that running versus the
number of people that we have we need to
get to a point where users can figure
out those issues by themselves
operationally as well so only we are
probably what do you want to move into a
stage of what he called the second level
support only when something goes really
horribly wrong then they have to come to
us so we wanted to get the system to
that level of reliability as well as per
actively then the third one is ease of
manageability so initially we used to
have manage our own clusters for storm
and everything which we don't want to
because there is a multi-tenant cluster
as huge cluster which is probably a few
hundred thousand nodes that are running
and we just wanted to piggyback on this
but as storm one of the issues was that
there's no notion of a resources
situation if I'm running a topology with
some X amount of resources and why
aren't uhm every it can potentially
exceed that so there's no notion of
those resource controls but as but the
new schedulers they have this control
using Linux II groups or docker
containers or whatever might be the case
so now we exploit all of those so that
we can run in a multi turn cluster
without having to worry about our
maintaining another cluster and all the
overhead that goes along with it there
we wanted to add more capacity which
means we go to procure new machines then
you have to go through these buying
process get those machines sanitize them
and add them to the cluster and put an
entry whose account that account that
goes to all the capacity management I
think it's much more simplified so some
of the design decisions that was we have
to deal with this fully ap compatible
with storm even though some of the API
would like to change but it's what it is
so it's all the Dijkstra policies for
and everything still works in heaven so
the point is like you just have to get
to a point where you compile the job
with the Heron jars without even
changing any single line of code so that
is our kind of what he called the goal
to get Heron into production so then as
I said the task isolation remarried
which means he's of debug ability and
resource isolation and you should be
able to profile your job
one of the major issues is hey where my
performance is going so I have no clue I
mean unless you can go do a heap dump of
it or profile that whatever that
instance whichever you think is slow and
you get the Deacon analysis of it boom
then you can fix the ratios and move on
so then third one is the use of
mainstream languages as how many of you
know what language Tom was returning yes
so so we are a little bit tough time
there because not many tools were
available in closure I mean even though
it's a nice language but more or less
plight but we had a lot of shortage of
people who know about closure and also
the number of tools that to do
mainstream development so since Ted we
stuck with the desire to move Herron
into more mainstream languages like C++
Java and Python which is very standard
languages that everybody knows internal
level there is no API in closure all the
pieces in Java yes yeah sure yes yes yes
so I will show you
the beauty of Haren is I say the name
micro steaming engine so if you want to
write your own language native in census
go for it
yes so like any from a developer point
of view you can bring your own language
do your own instances boom you're ready
to go so so the high-level Heron looks
like a another job for a scheduler so
like you submit a topology to an
scheduler and then it runs the Topol
uses any other jobs and except the only
difference is the job jobs don't run to
termination
instead they keep on continuing on till
you kill it so to give an idea about the
little bit of the internal architecture
of Heron each topology is assets one
notion of a master and that master is
responsible for the entire topology and
that the topology consists of multiple
runs on multiple containers and each
container has this several process
called one is the stream manager which
is responsible for routing data between
containers running in the same machine
as well as in across machines and the
metrics manager taps into all these
various other processes that are in that
container and gives you a very good
visibility about what is going on in in
the topology how much topples has been
emitted what is the latency experienced
by the tupple all kind of metrics I mean
the amount of metrics that we currently
see mind-boggling probably for every
topology will be collecting around few
hundreds of metrics then you can look at
those metrics figure out a by where this
is what's gone causing the issue and the
instances are where actual work is done
so if you remember like in the topology
that I mentioned where you have a word
tweet-tweet spout versus a for Street
bold words as a word count bold those
instances are the ones that are running
on these instances and these instances
are nothing but processes I mean
compared to storm which was a thread
based system we move into a process
based system because process based
systems do isolation give more control
over
heap dumping as well as profiling so
that's why we move into more process
based system and that worked out much
better
so then when the topology master comes
up it comes up in a container called
zero and that is the first thing that
the scheduler schedules for a topology
once that comes up and it sees a by the
way I need to get more resources of like
say 100 containers or 200 containers
then if go and talk to the scheduler and
the scheduler intern will say okay these
are the missions you can spawn your
containers off then the rest of the
other containers get spawned the first
thing that comes up in the container is
the stream manager so the steam manager
comes up and the first order of business
that it has to do is discover where the
topology must was running so SoDo
quality master when it comes up at
container zero it runs so only rights
and entry into the zookeeper or what we
call loosely as a state manager so it
advertised its location and everybody
goes and looks at the location in the
zookeeper to figure out where there are
addresses of the team a stress then
connects to a tea master and he must
knows how many containers it has spawned
off so all the containers have to report
back so once all the containers report
then it performs what we call as a
physical client and pushes that physical
plan down to those containers then once
the physical plan is comes into a stream
manager
each tree manager knows hey by the way I
can connect to other stream managers so
you form a body call as a fully
connected graph so so that's how the
current works and some of the sample
topologies that we run is you can see
the complexity is ranging from some very
few simple topologies which are like
four nodes or four components in a graph
to all the way to 50 components in the
graph itself so we have all kind of
topologies that are running up and
running now so so it has been production
for close to two years I mean we don't
give out the numbers but as I can say
like one stage to ten stages it varies
and it's huge massive stuff is all
running on top of today and some of the
use cases that I can give out his
sessions Lee like we do real-time ETL
for extract data transformations and
real time business intelligence and even
teams like product safety that they used
for continuously
like fraud detection and all the various
things on the real-time trends like all
that Twitter real-time turns are being
computed on top of it
tell me of some of the groups are doing
human moral enhancements moral building
everything in Haran as well and even
image processing lated stuff all running
top of heaven as well to where if
they're sanitizing images some other
stuff and finally real time ops also see
like us since we are running massive
clusters all over the board then
collecting data from those clusters
continuously and figuring out what is
the issues in the nodes in the cluster
and everything so we have those things
as well so I'm going to give a kind of
highlight on a couple of problems that
kind of we encountered that might be
good challenging problems that you might
want to think about so one is like we
are living the what he call is like
Hitler genius world so I mean you have
unmanaged schedulers like Eon and
missiles and there are like a bunch of
manage schedulers that has come up one
is Apache Aurora there which is runt on
top of missiles and Cuban it is which is
kind of managed on Amazon ECS is another
one that is Amazon has put out that
transit in the Amazon ec2 instances then
we have the marathon which also run top
or top of missiles similarly for estate
managers you can use zookeeper sometimes
even you can use the local file system
sometimes you can even use Hadoop and
similarly when you want to upload a job
you might want to use a Hadoop or even a
web or even an s3 if you're running in
Amazon context or even local file system
if you are running entirely topology in
your locals in this thing so in this
world what how can we write a core that
is not does not change but the Allah
other components can be plug-and-play
so this is what I want pieces that I
have is every problem in computer
science revisits every 20 years so like
I said ok let's go and look back what
did people have done so that's what
there's a notion of micro kernels how
many of you heard about micro kernels ok
so so the initially the the contention
was that the kernels are so monolithic
is very difficult to debug and all the
various stuff so then they'd said said
why we have to have all of them in the
end
as a monolithic instead you keep the
basic whatever we need and then the rest
of them could be model rice or
plug-and-play component that you can
write on top of that basic components
and that's the idea of micro kernels
were born so we borrowed the same idea
but the Heron and we call as the micro
steam engine so the basic thing that any
steaming engine needs is like an inter
and intra pcs ability to communicate
from one container to another containers
and in an eye either using some kind of
a socket shared memory whatever might be
the transport that you want you to
provide and that runs on top of the
hardware even hardware could be running
on any kind of network like on the GB
Network or a 10 GB network or even an
infinite band so you can exploit all of
them and similarly the notion of what do
you call SPI service provider interface
we borrowed the term from presto which
is another project that my team manages
and so the scheduler is an SPI which
means we write an abstract scheduler but
you can fit any scheduler underneath
whatever you like to so similarly you
can do a state manager SPI and you can
cook a zookeeper or a filesystem on it
underneath it so that way what happens
is a topology master does an internal IP
C steamer that said as IPC instance also
does an IPC and so does matrix manager
each component is replaceable at any
given time whatever you like to so that
comes to a point if you want to have
closure API you go and replace your
instance with the closure instance there
you go then you have an API so just it
takes a little bit more work than just
the prepackaged API but you can get
there so that's what we intend to do
with Python API and all the various
other language api's and even matrix
manager we where the collection of
metrics happens those are also goes to
scribe as well as graphite and there are
other things also people can write be
exposed or API you can write as well so
so there's three manager also even
pluggable to for example in the
streaming context there are different
processing semantics people want like at
least once at most one exactly once so
currently our stream manager supports at
least ones are at most once so we are
working on trying to get in exactly once
so this simple way to do is
put on another stream manager all your
dues in ApS a I want the semantics so
automatically the steam manager will be
instantiate the appropriate steam
manager will be instantiated so that the
whole idea is the core does not change
much so in a heterogeneous environment
so similarly the instance the topology
master is something that you don't fetch
all the time so but it that is also
replaceable if you know the protocol
that is interacting with so so what are
the advantages of micro steam engine
plug-and-play
environment changes the core does not
change so esteeming still moves the data
around second one is multi-language
instances support for multi-language api
can is much easier with and you get a
native instances to run that api if you
want to go instances right your go
instances and go api you should be ready
to go so that is a kind of level of
instances that you have done that so
then multiple problem crossing semantics
as I said efficiency manager for each
semantics so that for our most ones you
can write really screamingly fast one
whereas for exactly once you can write
very slow one because you want to
checkpoint the state and replay the
state of course this is also the site
benefit of doing this is ease of
development because teams can go really
fast without depending on other
components and it it increases
productivity quite a bit so this is the
environment that multi environment that
we run with so one is a local scheduler
so essentially what we do is for
developers like people who are working
inside had an infrastructure and
everybody they said like we don't want
to debug everything in the distributed
mode because it's very hard instead so
that that's why we designed the schedule
abstraction and we have this notion of a
local scheduler where you have a cluster
kind of running inside your laptop and
you can bring your entire topology as
though it is running on a distributed
nodes in a single laptop so that is
usually what we call this local
scheduler and then we also use local
state manage because I don't want to
depend on another zookeeper and all the
way stuff you can instantiate everything
local local and you are ready to go
ahead and is up and running and
similarly for cluster and testing and
other things we run it on me so slash
Aurora and where it uses zookeeper
estate manager I
we also use HDFS for uploading the job
and downloading to the nodes where the
schedule is actually running similarly
we are also for production we run it in
or order purely Aurora because our other
has some other functionalities that
missus does not have and we use Packer
uploaded which is the internal uploader
for jobs and everything which can do
even version management and all the
various stuff so that runs in plastron
production so why our aura because there
are some resource coders and are things
that it can enforce for example as a
team okay I have a reservation 4000
cores so you cannot exceed that so but
you can get as much resources as
thousand cores for all the jobs that are
currently running but the moment you
exceed that then you'll enforce those
quotas and of course we have
authorization because of whatever so
that also comes for free when you do the
authorization and also it does an
expressive DSL where you can describe
the job in or or or like kabadi call
it's a Python variation of it and it's
so easy to use and it also is highly
available and scalable there's a team
behind managing the entire aura and the
cluster is probably one hundred thousand
or something plus on so many nodes
running and a lot of didn't build ethics
comes for monitoring and debugging in
addition to the all the metrics that we
export about the particular topology so
now the second this is one of the very
important problems that we often
encounter in practice so the notion of
stragglers I mean in any distributed
systems the stragglers are the norm I
mean how many people have heard about
the term stragglers at least so in what
context have you guys got about it
Hadoop or okay so so it's not new but we
also observed that often it occurs in
streaming systems as well too
so on the three primary reasons that
occurs is because of something called a
bad host
especially in a large cluster something
is going to bound fail and you are
invariably bit scarier there is a time
gap between something happening to that
node versus can be detecting it and
eventually between the time you will get
SCADA matically scheduled and suddenly
the topology is going here where it say
what's going on under things so it's a I
mean among the stragglers 80 to 90
percent of the time that's what I keep
hearing all the time
so the second problem is executions q
for example in what he called in a
fields grouping when you have a hot key
like which tutor is known for a skewness
in the data and so the hot key can go to
a single node and a single process and
that process cannot handle what it is I
mean so that's what is called execution
skew and the third thing is what we call
is in aggregate adequate provisioning if
you're not provision the job correctly
in terms of resources your input rate
versus the processing rate is different
so if your processing rate is slower
than the input rate obviously you're
going to go into some kind of lag on the
input data source because you're not
able to clear that here so one of the
interesting problems in about the
inadequate provisioning is today is we
are doing manually in the sense like hey
by the way let me run this job on this
data source internal data source and see
how it works then after that I look at
some graphs or the CPUs like 80 and 90%
I need some leeway you know I have to
bring it down to 40 or 30 or 50 around
that right then I add more CPU resources
than lead on the job again so this is
like a hit and trial and error kind of
method that he keep on going until you
find a solution right but can we do a
better way on than just doing a manual
way and so I think like there are some
potential possibilities there but we are
not attempted it one of them it'll
involve some kind of simple machine
learning and sampling C one thing like
they can think about is like if you know
the data rates and if you sample the
data in a certain sampling rate like a 5
percent 10 percent when T percent on
automatically run these jobs on this
different sample rate and measure all
these various parameters and based on
that run some linear regression or
whatever it is and see whether this is
probably the amount of resources that
job will need so that is but the thing
is this if this can be automated and so
that the user are relieved from having
to do all of them trail and manual
because sometimes when they do trail
manual it is probably takes a day or
probably you in two days to get to an
optimal resources and with the provision
that there could be spike that is coming
so which means like whatever the optimal
resources you probably double X 2x or 3x
because you want to handle spikes right
so that is an interesting problem from a
data science perspective we have not
been able to solve it yet because our
rather we don't have the time to solve
it yet but that's an interesting problem
so so what are the approaches that we do
in order to handle stragglers so there
are multiple approaches then you can
think of one is whoever is sending to a
straggler just find that that that guy
is going slow and just drop it so that
is on some very simple method but though
it has its own pros and cons and second
aspect is centers slow down to the speed
of the straggler so in other words like
hey by the way that I'm sending to the
guy he is slow so I will also slow down
so then automatically the guy who's
sending to me also in slow down cells so
that it can propagate it continuously
then the third aspect is direct
stragglers and really schedule and these
are the potential possibilities so the
top data strategy where you drop the
data so one thing is unpredictable when
you especially when you're running a
large dag and I mean consisting of
several hundred containers running in a
massive cluster its unpredictable we
don't even know where the data is being
dropped and even if it is thought what
is the reason for it and sometimes it
affects accuracy I mean there are what
he called a feedback from people a by
the way if you drop the data then the
accuracy becomes like three inaccuracy
become 3x and especially if you are
sharing this data to our potential
partners the accuracy has to be as good
as it gets right so that's not a very
good thing so we need to be within a
bound of accurate accuracy so and also
gives poor visibility about where it's
being dropped and why it is being
dropped so slow down the sender strategy
where this provides more predictability
and they process data at the maximum
rate as possible probably at the rate at
which is slowest isn't clean and also
reduces recovery times because moment
the straggler becomes back to normal it
will pick up speed because that's what
happens right then all this also can
handle spikes because the data when it
arrives in spikes you might have a
temporary buffering and other things
that you already do so that you can
absorb the spike quickly
so so that slowdown ascender strategy is
what implemented in the heaven and so in
order to understand that like let's take
a look at this simple linear topology
with four stages and when this topology
gets realized in physical execution you
have these four containers and each one
of them has that four instances and if
b2 slows down then what happens is like
the steam manager that is pumping a data
into b2 will come to know about it and
it will send initiate a back pressure
hey by the way I'm experiencing some
back pressure because some of the
instant on of my instance is slowing
down so in response to that the steam
managers will go to directly to their
spots because if you look at spouts
order or you call the places where the
data is injected into a topology if you
slow down the data injection are
probably not even take data the whatever
they data that is currently in the
pipeline to be processed will
automatically slow down and that will
relieve the straggler slowness or
whatever that is assumption now so so
that is what you happen now moment it
finds that a by the way the b2 is fine
then again relieve that pressure
messages will be sent to those team
managers and then they will open up the
sports again the data will start flowing
so this is again what we do now you can
go into this if you open-close
open-close open-close if you can go into
the kind of flip flop mode so in order
to kind of avoid that or probably
minimize that kind of effect the stream
managers have this notion of buffers the
large buffers like where you can
configure something called low watermark
and high watermark and depending upon
where the data is in the buffer if it is
below the low watermark then you will
relieve the back pressure if it is above
the high-water mark then you will
initiate the back pressure so then now
one thing of a good thing about the back
pressure is if anything happens because
of the slowness of B to the lag will
show up only on the source so the moment
you lag shows up on the sword's you know
that some back pressure is happening in
somewhere and we also pinpoint what
instances in what container is causing
the back pressure then you can go on
look at that container
and machine and find out what's wrong
with that so that's why we identify
these issues so then so like for example
in this case so if there are something
that is going slow because one of the
containers one of the in process in the
container then essentially what it means
is like your read pointer is way behind
the right pointer because the lag is
continuously increasing right and
there's a possibility that if the right
pointer is way ahead then you can get
into a swapping behavior because there's
messaging systems like Kafka on are
things that io subsystems are not well
designed that if you fall back then if
some of the other topologies are
consuming out of the right pointer then
you if you are getting delayed then you
can go into swapping behavior where
you're trying to read from that a late
data and that has to be brought from the
disk to the memory and which in turn
affects all the topologies that are
heading at the top of the right I mean
very close to the right pointer so that
causes more problems actually so that's
one of the reason main rationale behind
designing our own messaging system then
that's called even bus and that solves
this problem mainly so so then so that
relieves a back pressure sometimes now
there are cases where the back pressure
could be sustained because it could be
because of some GC happened in that
container or because of that process is
talking to somebody externally because
in the microservices world what happens
is the streaming data would have to be
joined with some other micro services
and that might not be coming on on back
one time right so which means like
you're going at the case of the guy
because our data is not able to move
because you're joining with that guy
right and that could be another reason
so there are a bunch of other reasons
that you connect that can trigger
evaporation as well and so in practice
what we do is like in most scenarios
back pressure records without any manual
intervention we are fine I mean this is
the reason why we say this is because
compared to storm versus Heron number of
incidents that has gone down by 10x I
mean you won't believe the amount of
incidence that has gone on because
of the highly reliable and the
backpressure issues that we
automatically injected into the topology
itself then you even in spite of that
there are some issues sometimes that
happen which is sustained back up back
pressure and that is attributed to these
two reasons it recordable GC cycles and
the bad or faulty hose and bad or faulty
host means like that mission will
pretend that it is running it is running
something definitely yes but it's going
slower much lower than the other guys so
which means that cost hound everybody to
slow down and sometimes the user
preferred dropping off the data
sometimes what happens is some teams
come and say I mean well I don't worry
about what I call if the data is getting
delayed because of the back pressure and
everything I want to be at the top of
the T queue but I don't care about
accuracy at that point so so in order to
do that we do something called load
shedding like moment we see the distance
between the knife point or at the P
pointer at any given time and depending
upon what shredding strategy is boom you
can jump to the right pointer or sample
it and jump to the right pointer
whichever way it works so like this is
another big problem I mean detecting bad
and faulty hoes
so today our solution is pretty simple
actually
so you have this huge cluster of
containers that are running so in order
to detect these faulty hoes what we do
we run another head-on topology which
does gets the data from all the guys and
gets these topology running and these
topology will continuously collect the
data from these hundreds and thousands
of missions and see whether that mission
is reported data is good enough or not
then once it figures out the machine is
faulty it goes and informs the sre then
this sorry in turn will take that
machine out of the service now it's even
though it is running in real time there
is a huge amount of delay in terms of
getting reported then they sorry going
and taking the mission out so one of the
interesting problems or challenges to
solve is like when a topology is
continuously running so it does it all
sort of processes that are running and
you have all the data like the CPU sage
memory and all
various thing for every container every
instances and every process that are
running on that container so you owe all
of them now is there any way the moment
those data has come out can you figure
out these anomalies in execution for
example if a container is going slower
compared to the rest of the other
containers or the process on those
containers which are correlated to that
mission is going slow is can we identify
some kind of real time anomalies on the
fly so that the topology itself can
shoot down that container and a schedule
- schedule in a different one without
any manual intervention so that's a very
interesting and challenging problem
because one of the thing is we looked at
some kind of a playing by ocean or
machine learning algorithms one of the
thing that we want were like that team
back a team came back and told us like
we need two weeks worth of data for each
topology but the topology is something
that's always running real time and you
don't know what time the user is going
to kill it are going to start it again
right so whatever they when they start
they might not get the same data and
again you might schedule in the
different set of nodes which probably
affect the model that you've built on
top of it right so instead you end up
building the same model again so so
another thing is two weeks is probably
it's a long time to get a data before we
can identify any problem right and this
is again for every topology as he saw
the shapes and sizes of the topology
differ quite a bit so which means like
this has to run within the context of a
single topology and so so like then they
came back with a simpler solution where
hey by the way we can do threshold basis
for example if GC who simple rule based
a kind of thing where if GC is goes up
beyond a certain threshold boom alert or
whatever but again when you alert it it
might be okay for that topology for not
for other topology because at the end of
the day like if you are going to hook up
this to an alert system like a guy who's
waking up at 2 a.m. if you better have a
confidence at 95% otherwise next time we
feed our confidence of 20% is going to
switch it off is going to go to sleep so
when a real problem occurs right so the
confidence level has to be out attain to
that level so I mean so so we are
attacking this problem but we are not
there yet we are analyzing the
effectiveness of the algorithms
being more stuff to it but we are not
there yet if anybody has good ideas this
is an awesome problem to solve so so as
I said sometimes people wanted to drop
data and so there are a couple of
approaches that we looked at it one is
sampling based approaches where when you
have a read and write pointers or weight
then you can sample and go your way
around and when you sample do you want
upscale the results for example I know
that I am sampling at the source which
means like should this result should be
upscaled so that accuracy can be
maintained but it's very hard to do that
because if for example have Ania spout
this sampling you probably that is the
only spout that might be sampling but
other sports in the topology might be
okay but so which means you cannot have
a uniform sampling across all the spouts
and even if you wanted to achieve that
then there should be some kind of a
coordination layer between the spouts in
order to have that that's all getting it
correct is going to be extremely hard
and so so in in response to the amount
of or rather interview of the how much
implementation it will be involved so
bit is that sampling might not be a good
and even upscaling the sample is going
to be hard you don't know what the
computation is doing anyway are you
doing an aggregation are you doing a
median or a mode so how do you water
your scale so we don't know right so so
then another alternate approaches to
draw page a process where you simply
drop the data and go to directly the
wherever the right pointer is so sports
takes a lag threshold and lag adjustment
value and see how far we are from and
boom and that seems to work in practice
people are happy so that's what matters
so that's so now the before I go to the
next section which is morally about some
performance numbers and everything you
have any other questions before I move
further I think I've been talking quite
a bit
okay seems like crystal clear okay
anyway so so one of the thing that we
wanted to analyze was what is the
resource usage of henna
so when you have a topology running
where the time is really going am i
doing computation or am i doing data
movement which is causing that so you
not analyze that we did a cab a chore
breakdown of what that took where the
time is going for a topology and so this
is a simple stood two-stage topology
that we took and the input to that spout
is around sixty two hundred million
tuples per minute and they get filtered
to 8 to 12 million tuples and then on
each of the topple is blown up because
processing logic demands that the couple
is broken down into like what he called
a platform operation into five x tuples
so which means it increases to 40 to 60
million tuples when it comes out of the
spout itself and those forty to sixty
million couples per minute is shipped to
the next set of bold and that aggregates
that tuples that are coming in then
outputs the output that values every
second at the rate of twenty five to
forty two million tuples per minute so
this is and it's writing to a Redis so
this is the experimental settings and
all the numbers that we have in order to
run this topology so the number of
course the that we request 120 course
but the actual course that we were taken
as 30 to 450 even though like mostly
it's 30 to 45 actually and for readies
we just gave like two to four core
instances and memory requested is
unconsumed first 200 gb and only own ad
was consumed and memory a question for
ready servers just 48 gb which is the
entire machine itself now when we broke
down the where the performance is going
we saw the spouts were taking 84 percent
of the cpu cores like around the 50 per
source
84 percent of the course go into just
boats alone and bolt is complete noise
and heroness around 70 percent seven
percent of the
Aurel warhead so it's hardly anything
from a heron perspective now we were
curious why his pout is taking so long
so let's say like investigate further
more then the split is like this 63
percent of the data sorry goes into
deserializing
because we are taking data out of the
Kafka and deserialize it and that
consumes 63 percent of the course that's
where the bulk of the day is going and
then the filter operation which we do at
the spot level that also likes to take
six percent and some mapping and a few
computations that we do is also as noise
analytics percent and the other
interesting thing is the Kafka iterator
and the Kafka phase which are
essentially the core which we invoke at
the CAF card to get the data from the
Kafka that takes from sixteen plus seven
person that's approximately close to
twenty five person so I mean we couldn't
profile into that but this is what we
have machinery so so this is where like
as you can see fetching the notion of a
fetching data itself sixty-three percent
plus sixteen that was like seventy three
plus around 79 79 plus seven eighty five
percent of their spouts cost is going
fetching data from another source that
itself is a major issues so that's where
we are paying the penalty in terms of CP
course so then if you profile bolt which
is already a noise from the overall the
overall again it goes into a 68 percent
to writing data and to read is and some
amount of 19 percent goes into
serialization again the rest of them are
all noise simple aggregation
computations and all the radius things
are noise so if you look at the overall
so fetching data is in the overall this
thing is around 61 percent and the user
logic where you do is to an even person
of the whole cost and Hanover is around
close eleven percent overall and eight
percent is writing data so that is a
split so as you can see linear 50 core
if at 10 percent is five codes to run
this massive topology which is hardly
anything I mean unless you optimize a 90
percent that is going in you're not
going to see the improved mean harun I
didn't even make it like the 2x 3x
faster but that's not going to buy me
anything because the as you can see 90%
of the cost is going in
places wait so so it's a channel that we
have efficient bold efficient spout or I
mean to have a very efficient streaming
system so this is another one where we
did like a four stage topology which
takes quite a big amount of data and
when compared with the storm we got a 3x
reduction in resources as you can see
like the technologies enabled a number
of course were used was 350 or whatever
probably like like 10x reduction number
of course as you can see Heron was using
a lower course then what's Tom was using
with the no acknowledgement case where
this is a at least once at least once
this is at most once and again number of
course is drastically reduced so we
saved around the 3 to 4x total
introduction number of course when you
migrated everything from Tom to Heron
which was done like last year last first
quarter and massive savings so we got
there so and if you want to know more we
have the storm Twitter paper and Twitter
Heron streamings paper then the another
one is coming out and we oh one more and
the coming which summarizes all the
experiences that we had I mean I just
pointed out a couple of problems we have
more problems that we encountered very
we have a lot of solutions that we have
put in so those things will be on those
papers as well
that's all I had any questions yes
currently we don't do that so what we
have finished the design for it and
you're looking to implement it so one of
the thing is like two major approaches
that you wanted to do is source we blame
I mean if you for everything like okay
I'll count on the source to save the
data and give it to me then none other
one is you save the state in a bolt
itself so that they're independently
recoverable so they have enough state of
all the stuff and makes it independently
coverable because you can call them as
optimistic and pessimistic methods so
sources replace I will keep going fast
whenever something about some hours the
source will have the data and I'll can
always replay back and you know what
experience is what we have seen the
source replay is not a very good idea
because in strong if you look at the
utmost one semantics also counts on
source to replay back and we got badly
burnt by it actually so what happens is
sometimes you can go to the GCS and the
Victrola quiz don't return on time and
that means like the tuples will be
playback so if you go into vicious cycle
like that - easily the throughput of the
tuple sorry the entire this thing will
come to a grinding halt and you're not
you're just replaying tuples but you're
not moving further right so we have seen
such cases and so hence we are thinking
more on the lines of what he called
their independently recoverable
operators so that whatever the data they
get they save it on check point of data
and whatever they send it also check
point it so that even if I come and run
the same state that the other guy will
have its own state this tuple I have
seen I'm not going to take it right so
that way it becomes independent record
of all under worse scale it works much
better because it's autonomous right so
that's the one of the best property even
though it might go slow from a latency
point of view but since we have these
three different semantics you can choose
what are the semantics but there are
trade-offs if you want more on the
recovery in check morning yes you will
suffer latency but the upside of that is
that it's independent recovery and all
the various things become much easier so
yeah so like so we're working on it
what are you ventually come
yes we are working on it I think so yes
yes
so I think like I mean I would strongly
advise you to read that ahead on paper
because we outline 19 problems on that
so I mean I have a detailed slides on
this I didn't include in the talk
because that was eliminating the storm
problems and why heron was designed but
in the gist of it is like isolation was
not provided under the source management
and then a lot of GCS and other things
because of interplay of multiple tasks
in a single worker because tomat a
worker which in turn had what he called
all the tasks running within a worker
and that add a lot of issues because of
the multiplexing your to do
demultiplexing and if you look at the
architecture the amount of flow of the
path that duffel takes and going down
it's very different so that so now in
Heron we cut down all of them completely
and each instances just have only two
threads nothing else just a data input
use a logic processing out that's it and
making the system much more simpler and
taking advantage of some of the skill
areas and everything bought herring into
the all there's a cool stuff that we
wanted out of the essence of stuff that
we wanted
yes
yeah so all these things like in fact
like I can tell your story where one of
the teams was to their mourning in a run
book is every morning they have to come
and click what he called rebalance a
topology that is a run book they don't
know why they have to do it but it's a
part of the run book so then after we
push head on out we didn't have the
rebalance I said like why do you need a
rebalance in our no no no we are
supposed to have it and because the run
book is here can you figure out the
reason why it is having run book so they
they took this they sat down and we sat
with them and after they're like three
or four hours I'll probably the whole
day we spend on it oh there's a book
here then because Harun was doing the
logs and everything correctly and all
right
we were able to pinpoint the bug then we
fixed it they didn't even touch the
topology for the next three months and
after that they are when they did a
version upgrade then they upgraded it so
so like so there are so many stories
within Twitter where you can see like
how they were able to run errand without
having to having deal with lot of issues
you know some of the cabal is that has
been running for nine months without
even people touching it we have been
telling them can you move to a new
version because we are going to get out
of the older versions because the UI and
all the various stuff that your design
uses the some of the older photos right
you constantly keep updating them so but
again because the stability has become
another thing is like as a stream
manager and topology masters are written
in C++ and so no worry about DTC's or
anything because remember these are all
continuously running guys right and so
that relieved once the stream manager
has been debugged and sturdy we don't
have to touch it and the amount of
acknowledgments and other things it can
handle is very higher so which means
like in fact like we actually give on a
single container one core per team
manager that's a and we are not even
saturated that the one within a
container when you allocate a resource
you want some X amount of CPUs and a
amount of RAM right on the X amount of
CPU we do only one core for the steam
manager which did which is managed by
business order the scheduling of the
containers mended by Vsauce yes yeah so
within the container we control the
process what we run right so yes so then
those stream manager even though we are
only one core we thought we'll the
throughput is limited there if you look
at ahead and throughput it's limited by
the one co2 the steam inhalation solely
remember all the instances can run
really fast and pump data into this guy
because all the data has to go from the
steam manager either you and if you want
to bounce back to the same container
under another instance or if you have to
go outside the container and go to some
other container that also goes through
wires team manager so that single core
is very busy but if you not even hit
that 80 or 90% of those things yet sure
we do a C group c group container so I
mean we can make a docker also but we
don't do to use docker inside but I mean
when you package it you can package as a
daughter it's pretty straightforward so
your questions yes
so little later like I mean if out of
water data so I mean it's possible the
the data comes in and as long as it hits
the copper key will clear all of them so
we'll hear all of them and the guys who
are writing that they know the timestamp
where they're supposed to be returned
and they will go and hit that right
bucket and update that bucket whatever
they have to do yes
so joins is actually like we have some
bolts that do join but now one tricky
part is like if in the micro-services
everybody does joins in a different
service in a different way so we can't
make that pattern a little bit more
common unless these services are
abstracted in a like for example this is
a classic in the streaming context the
table versus the stream join so which
means like so your that table is format
is known or schema is known or whatever
it is then I can write a generic join
algorithm and boom let's go right
because how is the microservices guys
are constantly changing their thrift
interfaces or whatever right what you
get might be a little bit different
today and tomorrow right so which means
that the topologies they update the
stuff depending upon what attribute they
want and other things right
so in this cases it's a bit hot abstract
B of Carta body called as a store or
abstraction inside people use that
sometimes people don't even use that
they write their own stuff sometimes so
we just that that's why we have the
flexibility we have these three layers
of API one is the storm level or a Heron
level which is the low level stuff and
30 to 40% of the top Ollie's run on that
because they do some image crossing they
want low level control and all the
various stuff and then we have the mid
level API called summing board and all
the various things which allows you to
more express in a dsl kind of format
that's where all the stores and all the
various join could be happening then we
have one other thing called SAR
which essentially allows you to write
simple topologies using like what I call
a filter aggregate those kind of
three-stage topologies very quickly
right so that we can do that as well too
so any other questions yes
a state store state the volt state so
bold state are we currently like we
leave it to the user if you wanted to
write air state you can write to a state
to the user itself but now with the we
are seeing repeated patterns of it so
what we are going to do is we are going
to abstract that out so the state what
it can observe I mean some of the states
are so Bay for example some containers
that have seen or 30 gig on writing that
state 30 gay
how many disks you need in order to
clear that you fire how only one does
then 30 get divided 100 megabytes per
second that is a interval I can write if
you have then your despite that this do
multiple within a single node so let's
say a trial and I can't even go to high
CFS if you go to transfer 30 GB of bytes
of data how long will it take to
transfer over the network on a 1 GB
network or I ought to push that the 10
GB network without that it's not going
to work right so this is the problems
with the state so when you want to store
the state so that's why I like as we
upgrade the hardware and everything then
that becomes moral of it so I mean other
ways so always we lose the state we
build it up and so that the temporary
inaccuracies will be handled via some
other batch of the trance like every few
hours or so so that's the way we have
been doing it
mhm yeah you can do it like I mean you
can never move your own map and do it
right yeah so you can do that to you
u-turn leave you not built in but if you
wanted to built in one of the clear
advantage
I think that we were thinking was
probably a distributor that is kind of
thing that we can store and I was also
looking at how many of you guys have
heard about a project at Stanford called
RAM cloud so it is essentially like an
in-memory key value store with a carry
dick persistence because it replicate
the data in memory of three nodes like
then in its back only when the three
nodes fail you don't lose the data which
is similar to what Hadoop also does
right so but otherwise like it kind of
distributes the data and also if the
node comes no goes down then uses the
memory of the other guys not to recover
the data back so under then the data is
propagated torez disk asynchronously
because it assumes that other memory is
available right so that gives a
guarantees in terms of persistence right
another hand readies does not read is
like you store it and immediately
returns back and he is asynchronously
propagating it right so that's a very
different asynchronously propagated -
it's called Ram cloud yes so it's so now
we are looking into it like if you're
not made it to run yet but we'll see
where if that works very well then the
thing is like if it is just a pure state
for the operators now one of the other
thing is like the operators can store
the state in the distributed way then
even when the that operator goes down
and probably that machine has gone down
or whatever it comes back then on the
other node you should be able to pick it
up right that is one good thing another
thing that for an internal to the
Container one thing that we are was
investigating is shared memory a lot of
people underestimate the power of shared
memory since the shared memory is
available is similar to the memory
itself as long as somebody is holding
appointed to the shared memory it's not
claimed
operating system so the stream manager
is kind of an internal component so it
can hold the shared memory for all the
guys and all the state can be returned
on the shared memory so even if the
instance is not operated dies they can
come back up
and pick up the shared memory so which
means the amount of failures becomes it
is immune to the state becomes immune to
failures at the individual node level so
you can do that as well - so was it no
it's actually like 50 percent in C++
forty percent is sorry forty percent in
C++ fifty percent in Java and then some
Python so so as I said city manager and
the topology master return in C++
whereas instances return in Java and the
top under the scheduler abstractions and
all the various things are returned in
Java because they are all in the Java
world right and the Heron UI and all the
various tools are written in Python so
yeah so yeah so like I think like there
was some people who are asking can you
give me a C++ API I said what for at all
so that we need a high speed you know
it's not very hard to write a space that
because the I have to write a new C++
instance but Eva why we can provide the
API now citrus press is binary machine
binary right I mean the notion of
transferring the job to from one binary
if you are comparing the Mac and trying
to run an ascent was plus people not
work right
you ought to compile it on centers
cluster and throw it into a job right so
that is the only difference but it's
doable so similarly Python also we are
investigating now to make it work here
okay